ciao ragazzi bentornati sonorità story
stella dietro di sé berlino che far
rumore e non dovrebbe fare rumore perché
questa è una nuova challenge trova gli
ingredienti slime in cui non dobbiamo
fare il rumore che questa volta dovremo
trovare gli ingredienti slime è non
farsi beccare da un mister meet me
l'avete richiesto in tantissimi di fare
questa salvezza con mister mi chiede in
cui tantissimo praticamente mister mit e
un berlino al piano missili merlino
ma che sta facendo
berlino ti basta aprire la porta
vabbè comunque berlino ha deciso di tre
nella casetta di star mit e un macellaio
molto inquietante è il problema è che è
un macellaio macella tutti gli animali e
forse anche le persone non lo so
comunque devo fare e come rino ha già
paura come 8 di mister nyt e devo stare
super attenta a non fargli prendere
merlino quindi in questa challenge anche
il merlino è in pericolo e dovevo stare
super e attenta quindi mi raccomando
fate il tifo per me speriamo che berlino
non faccia troppo
il rumore come sempre perché dovrò
proteggerlo se mister mit prende merlino
avrò perso la salle come sempre dovrò
trovare tutti gli ingredienti slime è
fare lo slime prima di essere presa
altrimenti perdere la challenge dovrei
avere cinque o quattro possibilità non
ne sono sicuro perché penso proprio che
perderò questa volta visto come si sta
comportando un berlino mi raccomando
fate il tifo per me
lasciate un bel like se questo video
come sempre raggiunge i 40 mila likes
uscirà la seconda parte di mister nyt
berlino è tornato nella casetta tra poco
uscirà la seconda parte di baldi perché
ha raggiunto il 40 mila mi piace invece
per la terza parte di gremi andate a
lasciare un mi piace se raggiungi 60
mila mi piace uscirà la terza parte ora
sito e brolo
prendete le pastiglie i pop corn e
speriamo di passo che vediamo un po
esploriamo questa stanza vediamo se c'è
qualcosa magari c'è qualche ingrediente
slime qui che cosa è questo c'è scritto
scusate non si vede molto bene mister
meet the best place to eat
inquietantissimo guardate c'è qualcuno
che sta mangiando un pezzo di carne ma
non lo so la bocca e super malefica
oddio tra l'altro non ci avevo pensato
ma mister mutti nei feti e è ancora più
inquietante per me che sono vegetariana
non so se toglierlo magari se lo tolgo
riesco a togliere qualche
potere ammesso armi magari diventa più
debole se lo strappo proviamo con tim
hardin entro
[Musica]
ok se n'è andata per fortuna c'è il
gatto fuori che continua a miagolare qua
ora lo vedete meglio mister meet the
best place vuol dire il posto migliore
in cui mangiare ma ho paura che questa
sia carne di non lo so ma ho paura
ok nascondiamolo nella casetta
speriamo che non si arrabbi troppo ok
ora proviamo ad aprire la porta e andare
a votare super attenta berlino
vediamo
[Musica]
io l'ho visto
per dire di qua non per via
o no mi ha preso perché stavo cercando
di proteggere merlino altrimenti avrebbe
preso berlino e lo avrebbe fatto in
polpette
devo assolutamente proteggere berlino
berlino ma ti rendi conto che ti stava
per prendere mister mit perché fai
questa faccia così tranquilla dovresti
essere spaventato insomma non hai paura
a merlina non gliene frega proprio un
bel niente guardate quanto è tranquillo
andiamo ad aprire la porta sicuramente
di ingredienti islam sono tutti oltre la
porta e si sta tormentando meno male
così possiamo andare
[Musica]
si no
merlino più io ma marino non va e vieni
vieni bambino minimo in meno berlino vi
dico a berlino berlino vini
[Musica]
si stava per prendere berlino all'ultimo
momento pratico entrato berlino perché
puoi aprire la porta
chi fa quella mano e un bacio non
cercando di entrare
berna la tua potrei inserirmi prima
quando ti ho chiamato mai via perché
lombardia
[Musica]
ok almeno sono riuscita a prenderlo una
cosa perciò da la ciotola
almeno questo ora dobbiamo uscire
nuovamente e cercare di prendere gli
altri ingredienti ma è ancora più
difficile con merino perché non mi
ascolta quando lo chiamano non arriva a
poggio calciotto da e riproviamo
[Musica]
dall'occhio sara merlino ha detto
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no niente da fare ma vuole
per forza sia qui e chi no
[Musica]
io
no mi appresto di nuovo di berlino ma a
proposito la fine non c'è in questa
stanza spero che mi seguite non l'abbia
presa altrimenti berlino si sarà già
trasformato in un la salsiccia anche
persona charlene se devo andare a
cercarlo assolutamente è recuperarlo se
l'ho appreso ma vediamo la porta aperta
che strano
andiamo piano piano
[Musica]
piaciuto nessuna parte guardate
merino
no no no di qua
[Musica]
guardati dice la soluzione
si è qui che cos'è quel coloso prendiamo
prima questo
sapete cosa fantastica ho preso la
spatola e il bicarbonato
in più la soluzione partitelli mi sembra
così strano però che è stato così facile
prendere tre cose tutte in una volta
quindi ho paura che ci sia qualche
strana trappola linee alla soluzione
parlanti
proviamo a prenderla piano piano piano
piano allora nativa
ma dove lo scontro
aiuto aiuto di berlino berlino berlino
[Musica]
berlino vieni qua
berlino
bravo baleno bravo mi sembra rientrato
chiediamo la quarta berlino per
ottenibili da subito quando ti chiamo
che ho paura
oddio c'è mancato pochissimo mi
prendessi un'altra volta almeno sono
riuscita a prendere la ciotola e
bicarbonato e l'asfalto la ho visto
anche la soluzione per l'ente quindi
andiamo subito a prenderla non appena
mister mit si calma l'unico problema è
che non ho visto la colla da nessuna
parte
sicuramente sarà quella più difficile da
trovare perché mister mette molto futuro
può che proviamo andare questa volta
però chiedere merlino dentro diamo se
funziona
dietro che mi stava aspettando
eccolo lo vedete dobbiamo aspettare un
po che si calmi altrimenti mi prenderà
subito melino nel frattempo si è messa a
dormire ma come fa a essere così
tranquillo lui perché non sa che mister
miti potrebbe farlo a polpette sembra
che se ne sia andato verso sentito
rumori di una porta sarebbe bello se ne
andasse da qualche altra parte
almeno potrei prendere gli ingredienti
con tranquillità vabbè comunque proviamo
a prendere quella soluzione per lenti
che ho visto la colla proviamo a
cercarla dopo e la troviamo lì dove
essere la soluzione per l'ente sarebbe
troppo facile
[Musica]
ok via libera
io vado bene paura che si sia nascosto
quale a volte forte ma ripeto ok andiamo
a prendere non sono parenti
[Musica]
oddio che cos'è un nuovo costume minore
chiamata mi permetto ma perché
[Musica]
lo dico perché no
non devo chiudere la porta ma non posso
[Applauso]
no ci ha preso un'altra volta
berlino stai bene fammi vedere berlino
marina si per fortuna berlino sta bene
anzi sembra più allegro che mai ma
perché sei salendo sull'italia berlino
berlino sei contento che ti ho salvato
non sei contento che ti ho salvato
berlino non segna neanche un po ok
grazie per il bacino questo eletto
ringraziamento e ora praticamente mister
mit stava prendendo berlino
io avevo già preso la soluzione per
lenti anche se quel quel maiale faceva
rumore e infatti ha chiamato mister mite
quindi forse un suo alleato è
praticamente ho preso la soluzione per
lenti stavo scappando ma mister mit
insomma premio berlino e se non avessi
salvato berlino a quest'ora berlino
sarebbe un prosciutto una polpetta una
salsiccia non mi sto qualcosa del genere
quindi dovuto per forza salvarlo però il
problema è che ora abbiamo solo una
possibilità per trovare la colla
se mi prende anche questa volta avrò
perso il gioco è ovviamente non voglio
perdere voglio sconfiggere il mister mit
quindi speriamo di riuscirci berlino mi
aiuterai tu devi essere più cauto non
devi andare appresso mister mite capito
devi stare attento lui ti trasformo in
polpette e non permette vegetariane si
trasforma in polpette di carne e
speriamo che questa volta merlino faccia
da bravo comunque io sono comunque
riuscito a prendere la sfortuna ciotola
l'associazione per lenti
il bicarbonato manca solo la colla che
non ho visto da nessuna parte
quindi ora andiamo a cercarla
si no mi raccomando ok abbiamo la porta
berlino già pronta ossibile
[Musica]
quando mi sembra che si sia d'accordo
forse dovevo stare meglio qua
ma cosa c'è in questa volta
[Musica]
ma questo è il maialino di prima ho
capito sicuramente il maialino non buone
che io entri in questa porta le farà
rumore se io entro in questo porta
sicuramente quindi probabile che ci sia
qualcosa che faccio apro la porta
ho continuato esplorare ma sono troppo
curiosa devo aprire la porta speriamo
che non facciamo
[Musica]
ecco la colla ragazzino che cos'è questo
dei raggi ics e profonda e nella la
stessa
mi farò prendo tutto possiamo alzare
quei ragazzi qui i raggi che cose che
fanno scattare l'allarme
berlino di questo non fuori come faccio
solitamente salvarlo per questa è la mia
ultima possibilità berlino miu miu miu
giusto in tempo
ma il dom all'avvio di bari bella natale
hai capito che mi permetti ti trasforma
in un salamino ok la questione lato via
devo riuscire entrare in quella stanza
superando i raggi ics
ora provo nuovamente entrare in quella
stanza proverò a scavalcare i raggi ics
o cosa sono senza far scattare l'allarme
[Musica]
ok cucciolo camera qua
[Applauso]
oh mio dio
prima di trasformi berlino il mio
polpetta fidiamoci sbrighiamoci specie
poi se sprechiamo ciò che è qui per
fortuna non ha preso merlino ancora non
devo sbrigarmi per lo studio di posso
farlo ai ragazzi
ecco qua mette subito la colla
io spero che male ecco ho messo la folla
ne metto pochissimo poi vi riescono
attiva da subito
spero che meriti al talco pomeriggio
servizi eccellenti velocemente è ancora
lì ancora lì che mi sta guardando ma
conta quello che sto facendo pretesto
scopiamo mescoliamo mescoliamo
mescoliamo velocemente giunte niente
sbrigati ad attivarsi perché ci mettono
sempre presentato nel club ad attivare
che ci si
e qui e là
un no e quella finestra non penso che
rete 3 dalla finestra
però io ci sono quasi quasi pronto ci
siamo quasi collettivo collettivo
per fortuna anche se questo slime
minuscolo è piccolissimo però sono
riuscito ad attivarlo l'abbiamo fatta
abbiamo vedere dove berlino adesso
perché non è entrata muoverà merlino
berlino berlino berlino forse qui a
berlino berlino berlino no ora dovrò
andare a cercare merlino e sperare che
non sia stato trasformato in una
salsiccia new slot oper a berlino la
saces like se volete vedere il continuo
in cui dovrò riuscire a trovare merlino
sperare che non sia stato trasformato in
qualche salume se questo video raggiunge
i 40 mila mi piace assisterà il
controllo non mi dovrò provare proprio
mi raccomando da state un bel mi piace e
ora vi lascio qua 4 casellina su cui
cliccare per vedere i miei altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite